- Wie lange haben Sie Frau
González nicht mehr gesehen?
- Ungefähr zwei Wochen.
- Und …
hat sie denn nicht gesagt,
wohin sie geht?
Wissen Sie nicht, ob sie verreisen wollte?
- Nein, sie hat uns nichts gesagt.
- Warum haben Sie die Polizei
nicht früher informiert?
- Na ja. Jeder kann mal zwei Wochen
weg sein, oder?
- Haben Sie ihre Handynummer?
Haben Sie sie angerufen?
- Ja, aber ich erreiche sie nicht.
- Das sind meine Eltern.
- Was machen denn Ihre Eltern?
- Mein Vater ist Anwalt und meine
Mutter Ingenieurin.
- Glauben Sie, dass Ihre Tante in
Spanien ist und Ihre Eltern besucht?
Können Sie Ihre Eltern anrufen
und fragen?
- Sie ist sicher nicht dort.
Der Kontakt ist nicht sehr gut.
- Wo in Spanien wohnen Ihre Eltern?
- Meine Eltern wohnen in Sevilla.
- Hm … Na, dann schauen Sie mal hier.
- Was macht Yara in der Schweiz?